oh okay I've never used that expression
[Music]
hello hello welcome back to certified
country I am so excited you guys today
Kellie Pickler is in the studio with us
and congratulations are in order of
course
Pickler and Ben has been picked up for a
second season we're so excited we have
had a ball so far and we're excited that
this little roller coaster route is
gonna keep on going we're gonna
hopefully just continue to grow and hope
that our audience will grow with us and
have grace for our mistakes we just want
to keep it positive and uplifting I want
to talk about this beautiful new single
that you have out
[Music]
first of all thank you for saying that
because the song is so special to me
I wrote the song with my husband and our
dear friend Brian Bunn at our kitchen
table on the anniversary of my
grandmother passing and she was the
woman that raised me she was the woman
that I called mom so this song was
really to shine a light on her love and
her grace and you're getting emotional
even just talking about a legend like
Grandma yeah I want to talk a little bit
about some of the women in your life
word association starting with mama fey
grace now your idol Dolly Parton oh wise
I don't I'm just country music royalty
that's more than one word but it's true
and we'll pass is one word I've loved
her since she was little thing and young
in the business and now look at her
doing all good your executive producer
faith health incredible your co-host
wife ginger Zee she's very intelligent
it's just funny now our new Idol judge
Katy Perry she is I mean I throw our
[Music]
your Idol co-star calculate fee just one
of the most angelic voices I've ever
heard now your old pals Taylor Swift huh
I mean she's Elijah and Carrie Underwood
oh my types
[Music]
now we have to talk about Idol for a bit
and you tell us any more about how
you're gonna be involved in the reboot
well I hope to be involved at some point
I think you may send an invitation then
I'll be there for sure
do you still get a little bit of that
jitters though oh yeah when I hear that
theme song from another room yeah I'm
like I can hear a ryan going I'm late
now when you're in LA or when you're
traveling in general does your hubby
Kyle join you oh definitely he's not
here this trip I'm in the studio but
when his schedule works with ours then
he's out here for sure how do you guys
deal with such demanding schedule we
know that in the day we are the number
one priority for each other we have to
protect our sanctuary which is us being
that we're doing Pickler and been in
Nashville 15 minutes from the house I
clock in in the morning I clock out at
night and I get to go home and have
dinner with my husband and Ben's the
third wheel nine times out there but we
love it
we always make sure that we make us a
priority he's a good man
yeah he's a good man he's caper I think
now the last time I saw you was in New
York and we had you and Kyle together
playing the better than newlywed game
what is the first thing your spouse
would buy if they won the lottery
you can't put shoes you can't put you we
had so much fun I wanted to play another
game with you today southern charm with
Kellie Pickler I am gonna read you a
southern term and I want you to define
it for me okay well I might not know it
well we'll see Arkansas toothpick an
Arkansas toothpick have you heard this
no I have not apparently it means a
large knife huh well let's see the next
one caddywhompus like caddywhompus okay
that's how you say it kind of a little
off like gelo caddywhompus I like it
right to find the little cattywampus I
know the card all right well this one
you definitely know darn-tootin know
what kind of tune you're talking about
not that guy not that kind
goobers
does this one have multiple meetings and
how it depends on a re your your Gabe
feel like it you're a goob goobers mean
peanut or but I like your definition of
your peanuts that's right do you say
boiled boil boil hoecake okay it's a
small cake made of cornmeal a hoe cake
well haha
what about piddlin piddlin like
lollygaggin and pit quit pissing around
okay there we go get out get out get off
get my grandma with always big get don't
plunder don't plunder don't plunder what
does that mean don't go through somebody
else's things like if someone's over at
your home and they're plundering through
your bathroom you know everybody being
nuts for this one at all
yeah these ones go hand-in-hand yeah
well thank you so much for being such a
good sport in Callaway for educators
stuff that I should know thank you guys
so much for watching as a reminder you
have until midnight on Friday the 23rd
to enter for a chance to win tickets to
see Maren Morris and nyle horn at the
u.s. city of your choice be sure to
enter at ET online.com slash giveaways
be sure to subscribe to Entertainment
Tonight on YouTube we'll be back again
next Friday with a brand new episode and
in the meantime be sure to check your
local listings for new episodes of
Pickler and Ben
you